you still believe when they go low we go
high after all that is happy you know
what's the alternative
you know because going low means you're
operating from your place of emotion you
know it doesn't necessarily mean you're
operating from a place of results more
often than not you don't get results
when you go low you just you know get
your attitude out you know and when
you're in the when you're in the white
house and you have that platform and
that responsibility where every word
matters you know you're often thinking
at least Barack and I often thought is
what we're about to say going to help is
it going to move the needle forward or
is it just going to make us feel
vindicated in the moment and you learned
that vindication in the moment is so
short term you know the goal is moving
forward I make the point that going high
doesn't mean you don't feel have
feelings and that you don't express
feelings you know that you don't that
you don't acknowledge hurt or pain or
anger you know that's not what going
high is going high means now you now you
have the feeling how do you express that
feeling in the world and how do you do
that responsibly